our dr. David agus joins us now from his
home in Los Angeles David good morning
morning Anthony David David the the FDA
has authorized a test that can produce
results in as little as five minutes how
reliable is this test and how
significant could it be well it's five
minutes for a positive result thirteen
minutes for a negative result from
Abbott Labs and it's transformative in a
sense when a patient comes to you I can
get the result while they're there and
tell them what to do it's the same test
that was used for strep throat and in
for what influenza now they have it for
Co bed 19 and they're gonna be doing
about 50,000 tests initially a day
across the country in the hospital labs
and Clinics I'm excited for the
management on my patients no question
about it
yeah and it's accurate you think David
no question I mean this accuracy it's
the same technology we're looking at a
hundred letters of the 30,000 letters of
the viral code so the same as the
previous chest but just the hardware
enables it to be happen much quicker and
easier
okay David president Trump has says the
FDA is also approved a process to
sterilize the n95 masks that hospitals
need so desperately how's that gonna
work and do we think that's gonna help
the problem in hospitals right now well
it's certainly a piece of the puzzle in
that this technology from Patel in Ohio
is basically a room where you can put in
40,000 masks at a time and with an
aerosolized gask it can kill the virus
and so two and a half hours later you
have a mask that can be used again each
mask can be used 20 times so every time
it's sterilized they mark it and at 20
they throw it away so that's almost 20
times more masks if you think about just
the simple numbers there so things like
this innovation from America or what's
gonna make us hopefully win this war all
right David Icke dr. David agus thank
you David